[Inaudible].
That's going to be difficult, work on the new letter.
Okay.
All right. It's good evening, everyone. Or good morning or good afternoon,
whatever it is, wherever you are. I actually can't see my own stream,
but I can hear my voice through the headphones. So, so I know you can hear me.
So let me take this off. So I don't hear an echo. Uh, okay. Yeah.
I don't know how I can see my own stream. I can't see the comments right now.
I can't see anything. Let me, um, give me a minute.
Let me try to figure that out. Uh, hold on a second.
I want to see your comments while I'm streaming.
So let me try to figure out how to find it. I haven't done this in a long time.
It's been about two years since I've done a live stream.
We'll do this.
[Inaudible].
I don't mean to keep you waiting.
I just want to be able to see the comments in this doesn't seem the same as last
time a YouTube has changed something.
I've got to figure out the new way, or at least you can see me and hear me.
Um, if I can't figure out how to, how to see the actual stream,
then I'll just do it and, uh,
let you guys listen and watch and just hope that everything's going fine.
Okay.
Okay. I'm going to try to, to watch it on my own phone,
because that seems to be the only way I can get to my own stream.
YouTube. What are you doing while you're playing with me?
So I'm actually using my phone and searching for my own channel so I can see my
own screen, my own stream. This is getting weird.
Okay. Well good. Okay.
Now the wrong thumbnail is there.
It also has the wrong thumbnail. Okay.
Now I can see my own stream and I can see the comments on the screen.
Okay. All right.
So I see someone from Brazil. What's up Brazil. I see Holland. Uh,
let's see. Someone said you are weird. Indeed. You are correct. That is true.
She led what's up. I know you'll, you'll be, um,
extremely annoyed if I call it chili. So it's chili
Czech Republic. Someone said I'm getting old. Well,
when do you expect five years have passed since the start
Afghanistan. Cool. Switzerland, Germany, Italy,
Egypt, India, Brazil. Uh,
alright, well, I should, um,
get started actually speaking to you guys and not just shouting out all the
different countries and getting oriented. Sorry.
It took me so long to figure out how to actually see the stream. Um,
crazy times. Uh,
the world is crazy right now because of all the stuff that's going on with the
coronavirus and people under lockdown.
I know a lot of you are stuck at home and you can't go to work, uh,
or you can't go to school. Um, or maybe you're doing teleworking from home.
Maybe you're doing online classes for your university or your high school or
whatever. Um,
so a lot of people are stuck at home and just having a hard time adjusting
to this new reality. So I thought I'd talk a little bit about that today and,
um, talk about how you can sort of, um,
be happy and healthy when you're stuck at home when you're not used to that.
And then also how you can use that time. Well, you can use it productively, um,
to learn or to improve yourself, improve your life. So let me just, um,
let me get into it and, um, let's start going.
So, um, about being happy and healthy at home.
So I'm kind of used to staying at home a lot because I do Lang
focus. I work on Lang focus for long hours at home.
I don't work at Starbucks or in an office or things like that.
I usually do it at home.
So I'm kind of used to just being at home a lot and I've had to learn how to not
go crazy and, um,
learn how to be productive and just also feel good when I'm at home.
So these are my thoughts on how to be happy and healthy at home.
Um, it's easy to get bored and it's also easy to get depressed when you're at
home all the time when you're not seeing anything new, um,
when you can't get out of the house very much and, uh, for a change of pace,
um, depression's very common when people are stuck at home. Um,
so some things you can do,
one of the most important things to do is to exercise by the way,
these are all just, you know, this might be obvious,
but these are just things that, um,
I think are important and things that I try to do.
So I'm encouraging other people to do them too.
So exercise exercise is important,
not just for like looking ripped and looking good,
it's it is to maintain your physical health and to maintain your mood.
And that's a part of it that not everyone really thinks about exercising
improves, your mood, gets your blood flowing. Um,
it just helps you to feel better. And if you're getting depressed, um,
exercise is a very good way to alleviate that. And that's an important thing.
If you're stuck at home a lot, I've been exercising every morning.
I normally do anyway. Um, but I,
I made sure to buy some exercise equipment and get on top of exercising at home,
uh, during this semi lockdown period, you're in Japan.
We're not fully under lockdown, but, um, we're not supposed to go out that much.
And I haven't been going out very much at all. Only it's the supermarket really?
So you can exercise at home with equipment or without equipment.
I have some equipment, I have some dumbbells and I bought a pull-up rack.
So I've been doing pull ups and chin ups and, um, and dips on the pull-up rack.
And I've been doing push-ups and sit-ups um, but you don't need equipment.
There are a lot of things you can do without equipment. If you can do pushups,
sit ups, you can do leg raises, you can do squats,
you can do squats while you're holding something. I hold dumbbells when I do it.
But, um, some people hold cartons of milk or they hold, you know,
boxes or whatever. You can hold something to increase the weight.
So it's more like you're doing squats at the gym,
even though it's probably not quite as heavy. Um,
so the goal is not to be jacked or ripped, right?
It's to get your blood flowing and increase your heart rate.
So even if you don't have the best equipment in the world,
it's not like your gym, at least you still have, um,
you still have something and you still have a chance to get your blood flowing
and feel better. So it's really about being healthy, both physically and man.
Yeah.
Okay. It's exercise. That's one thing that I think is important too,
to keep doing, even when you're stuck at home,
the second thing is strive to be productive.
Don't just consume by consume. I mean,
like you just take something in like you watch TV or you,
you use social media or you listen to music that's consuming,
but it's much more, uh, it's much better for you if you are productive,
if you produce.
So, um.
Yeah, if you only consume entertainment,
it's much easier to start feeling a sense of despair. Um,
because you're basically sitting there passively and you're not really taking
control of anything. So especially in a situation like this,
where we feel so helpless and like things are out of our control,
it's much better to be productive because you, um,
you feel like you're moving forward and you are actually taking control and
moving forward and progressing beyond this current situation.
So that's very good for your,
your mental health and just your mood in this sort of situation. Uh,
I skipped one line here. Uh,
social media can be terrible for your mental health.
So that's part of consumption these days.
Most people consume a lot of social media and it's starting to replace TV a
little bit,
but social media is not very good for our mental health in a lot of ways.
I mean, dealing with the comments, there's a lot of, um,
sort of conflict in the comments and a lot of, um, people get angry and it's,
it's easy to argue with people and then you feel bad when you argue and that
kind of thing. And then there's all of the, the comparisons, you know,
comparing yourself to other people and how they portray their lives on social
media, all of that stuff when you're stuck at home and you,
you probably consume more of that than it's even worse for your mental state.
So avoid all of that consumption, consumption, um,
think about working on a skill or developing a skill because that gives you that
sense of mission and progress. So maybe I'm stating the obvious,
but I'm just sort of telling you my thoughts and showing you that I care.
So one obvious choice, uh, one obvious mission that you can,
that you can take up is to learn a language.
Obviously you're all language enthusiasts. That's why you watch this channel,
but it doesn't have to be learning a language, just do something productive,
just so you feel happier and feel that sense of satisfaction and progress.
And you don't get depressed when you're stuck at home.
Okay.
So here are some general ideas for how to be productive and how to focus when
you're at home. This is not only about language learning.
I'll get to some specifics about languages later, but right now,
just in general, how can you stay focused and be productive at home?
Because it's not easy at first. Um,
I work at a university I teach during the semester, but I have long breaks.
This break that I'm on now is normally three months.
So the first month when I'm off,
it's usually a big shock to my system and I have to, uh,
adjust and figure out how to focus again when I'm at home for such a long period
of time. So I'm kind of used to this, to here are my ideas on that.
So the first idea is to have a specific place that is your productive place.
Um, so I have this little office room right here, maybe. Um,
let me skip back so you can see I'm on scene 15. Okay. Uh,
let me go back for a second. So I have this little office room right here,
where I use the computer for editing and for doing research and stuff.
This is my productive space. So when I'm not being productive,
when I'm using the computer for something, something fun or for consumption,
then I take the computer into the other room.
I go sit at the kitchen table or sit on the sofa.
I try to divide those places into productive and unproductive place.
I have one particular place to be productive. Um, when you do that,
you start to associate that place with productivity.
So if you, uh, use that place for unproductive activities,
then you'll start to connect that place with that unproductive stuff.
So it'll be harder to get into the zone and focus when you want to be
productive. So have one place set aside for that for me,
it's this room right here. Second thing. Now, this thing is, um,
something, some people are kind of cynical about, which is meditation.
Now. I don't mean like spiritual or religious meditation. Uh,
not like that. What I mean is just, um,
sort of relaxation and breathing exercise to calm down, um,
to relax your body and clear your mind. Um,
it clears the mind and it prevents distraction. Um,
if you're,
if you want to work for a few hours and you just spend like five minutes at the
beginning, meditating, then it's much,
much easier just to get started and to focus. And you don't have all of these,
um, these random thoughts and ideas popping into your head.
And if they're there, they're quiet and in the background,
they're not that distracting.
And you don't think about things like I'm going to check your,
your smartphone or, you know, all of the other things that you want to do later.
You don't think about them as much. If you spend five, 10 or 20 minutes,
meditating, 20 minutes is a bit hardcore,
but 10 minutes you can do that. That's great.
Or even five minutes or just two or three minutes, uh, to start.
So what I do to meditate is I just focus on my breathing and I
focus on a candle. So let me go back again and just go back to the scene.
I have little candles like this and in my productivity room and my little office
right here, um,
I like this candle and I just stare at the flame while I breathe slowly and
focus on my breathing and that's it.
And maybe my mind will drift off and think about something else.
But when I notice my mind is drifting,
then I just bring my attention back to the candle flame and to my breathing.
So it's basically two points of awareness, my breath and the candle.
So if I do that for about five minutes, 10 minutes, sometimes 20,
if I'm doing it consistently, then that keeps me focused for hours at a time.
Then if I get distracted again later, I can pause and, uh,
and meditate for a few minutes again. And just to get my attention back,
I find it really good for clearing the mind. Uh, where were we? Okay,
so that was point number two.
Another idea is to put your phone in the other room,
put your phone in the other room. Um, we have an impulse to, well,
let me backtrack for a minute. Um,
most of us these days are really addicted to our phones and we always have this
impulse to pick up the phone and to check our, um,
check our messages or look at Instagram.
What we're really doing is seeking stimulation, uh,
because you get that stimulation that dopamine hit.
Whenever you pick up your phone and you, you see something new,
your phones are designed to, to be like that designed to be addictive.
We're all kind of addicted to them. But if you put it in the other room,
then it's out of reach and you're less likely to pick it up
because we have that impulse to pick up the phone,
but we have a different impulse to stay seated where we are.
So if you're sitting down, you usually don't want to stand up.
You'd rather just stay seated because it's easier when you're in that sort of
passive state to sitting in your seat.
So you can use that tendency of wanting to sit.
You can use that to prevent yourself from picking up your phone.
So it's put your phone in the other room and you probably won't go and pick it
up. And if you do well, it will probably be later than you.
You would have done it. Otherwise let's put your phone in the other room.
It works. Okay. I just said that.
Okay. And if you do use your phone for something productive, um, uh,
for example, if you use the, um, like On-key and SRS,
a language learning app, or if you do some kind of work using your phone,
then avoid the junk. Try not to use Facebook,
try not to use Instagram, um, avoid those as much as you can. Um,
but then again, we're addicted.
So what can we do if we're addicted and we can't help ourselves? Well,
there's a social media hack. This is what I do. Um,
I load my timeline with productive content so that even if I
open it, I don't really waste time. So for me, what that means is on Facebook,
for example, I only follow stuff that's in different languages.
Like I read the news and Indonesian or watch videos from CNN, Indonesia, or,
you know, I subscribe to TV channels and Israel,
so I can watch TV shows in Hebrew. Uh, I get the news and French.
So that's, that's my whole timeline these days. So even if I,
I do open Facebook in a moment of weakness,
then it's fine because I'm actually doing something productive.
So that's the social media hack.
Just prevent yourself from wasting time looking at funny cat videos
or whatever, but loading your timeline with stuff that's useful for you.
Okay. Uh, another idea, this is an idea, um,
for procrastination,
this is a mental hack for how to mentally get over procrastination.
Most people do useless things first and put off their productive work for
as long as they can. So switch those things. You can still do both,
but switch them. Uh, so what I mean, what,
let me go back to the I'll show you my, my space here again.
So most people usually do the unproductive activities first,
and then they do the productive activities later.
They put those off as long as possible or I'll study later, or, um, you know,
I'll do my work later and they keep putting it off,
over and over and they do the fun stuff first. So switch those,
switch your focus to, to the productive stuff. Tell yourself, okay,
I'm going to do this fun, this productive stuff right now. The fun stuff. Okay.
Yeah. Well, I'll do it sometime. I'll do that later. Not yet. I'll just,
I'll do it sometime. Not yet.
Just keep putting it off the way you would normally put off your work.
You would put, normally put off your productive activities.
So switch that and put off the fun stuff or the unproductive stuff.
Just do that sometime in the future later,
and then keep telling yourself that every time, if you want to do it,
tell yourself later, later, maybe tomorrow, or maybe tonight,
every time you have the impulse to do it, push that back into the ends of the,
uh, yeah. Push it off into the future. Sorry.
It's late here and I'm kind of tired. So I'm, uh, getting off track of it.
Uh, okay. Right.
So switch the focus from the unproductive activities to the productive
ones, push the unproductive ones often to the future,
as far as you can keep pushing it back. Okay. Let me find the slide where,
where I was. I forgot what slide I'm on social media. We already passed that.
Okay. Switch them here we are.
Okay. So those are some ideas for productivity in general,
for how to stay focused at home. Um,
now for learning a language at home specifically, here are some ideas.
People tell me, well, I can't go out and speak to people, right? Um,
but now we have the internet. So you don't exactly need to,
you can do an online language exchange.
And right now lots of people are at home. So they're bored too. They have,
you know, lots of time on their hands.
So it's probably easier to find language partners at the moment.
So if you actually look for some, you could probably find them.
You might find some in the chat right now, who knows. Um,
but if you join one of those sites, like, um, like I,
talkie is one where you can find Landry language exchange partners. Um,
there are apps like, hello, talk and that sort of thing,
where you can find language exchange partners. That's a good idea.
And then you can jump on Skype and you can actually talk to them,
Skype or zoom or whatever you use. Um,
you can actually meet them and speak to them online,
just like a real language exchange partner. So that's one idea.
Another thing is another thing you can do is to take online lessons.
You can use a site like I talking to book lessons on Skype or whatever. Um,
and then talk to them on Skype.
I talk to you is usually it's not always informal,
but the focus tends to be on informal tutoring.
So it's a way to get conversation, practice and get some feedback, uh,
about your, about the way you're speaking about your, your skills.
Uh, if you want to take more serious lessons,
then there's stuff like lingo data, or there are language schools like, um,
there was another one live lingua, I think is another one.
There are online language schools that actually provide courses for you.
So that's another option. If you want something that's more laid out for you,
but I usually use, I talkie it unless it's a language that I'm,
I'm just beginning it.
So here are some ideas for how to get started on your own. Using,
I talked to you doing a language exchange. That's usually, you know,
when you already know a little bit of the language and you want to apply what
you you've been studying to, you get some conversation practice. Um,
but what if you're just starting out?
What if you are bored at home and you want to pick up a new language? Well,
here are some ideas to get started. Um,
different people do it differently and maybe these aren't revolutionary,
but these are some ideas in case you don't know what to do.
So you can get started by listening to the language a lot,
just getting used to the sounds of the language.
You can listen to YouTube videos, you can listen to podcasts. And by that,
I mean, podcasts in that native speakers. That's a good way to, to get,
uh, to get used to the sounds of the language so that later on,
you can imitate them and be able to understand them because you're learning to
distinguish between all the different sounds.
And after you've done some of that,
you've gotten used to the sound of the language.
Then you can use a course with audio. So my course,
I don't mean like apps. Um, there are internet based courses that are good.
I'm sure I'm more familiar with the book and audio courses, uh,
that were, that were big when, when I was younger, because I got used to those.
So, you know, I like courses like, um, teach yourself as, okay. I like,
um, uh, lingua phone, the old lingo phone courses, um, stuff like that.
There were a lot of different, uh, audio and book courses that are quite good.
Another one is, um, living language. It's another one. Um,
but worked through the course,
work through the book and listen to the audio a lot and also shadow the audio.
I'm quite big on shadowing. I think that's a great way to, um,
to learn how to pronounce the language. Um,
and also you're also internalizing some of the sentence patterns when you're
shadowing them and that sort of thing I've found, uh, shadowing very helpful.
It's something I've been really into the past couple of years. Uh,
and you can,
so you have that main course and you work through it with the book and the
audio, but you can also supplement with other materials,
like a pod one Oh one site,
or with lessons on YouTube that are dedicated to learners of your target
language, that kind of thing.
It's always good to have some extra materials just to, for extra stimulation,
just to make your learning journey more exciting for you.
And you get all that extra exposure to the language. Um,
and it's always from a different angle or maybe the topics of different and that
kind of thing. It's always good to have multiple sources
and then you can speak with people to apply it.
So that brings us back to I talk to your language exchanges.
So that's kind of for beginners, I guess, for people who are getting started,
but what if you're more advanced? There are a couple of things, um, you know,
a couple of things you can do,
you can consume content in that language consume content.
That's a fancy way of saying like, you know,
listen to audio and watch videos and that kind of thing consume content just
means that so you can, uh, you can, you know,
listen to podcasts, you can watch Netflix shows in your target language.
You can read the news in your target language, that kind of thing.
So that content, that authentic content becomes your textbook.
You can learn the vocabulary,
you need to understand a video or a news article or that show, uh,
or a novel, if that's what you want to do. And then that becomes your textbook.
You focus on that content and you learn whatever you need to learn in order to
understand that content. Oh, wow. I just, um, I'm just, I'm just seeing,
um, I'm looking off to the, sorry,
I'm distracted by my phone. Uh,
let me go back to, to my office right here.
If you're just tuning in, uh,
I should let you know that I can't really see what's going on in the stream. Uh,
I can't see it on the computer. So I had to open up my cell phone.
My iPhone is right here on the side. So if you're sending, if you're sending,
um, super chats or whatever, I might not see them.
Maybe I didn't see some of the earlier ones,
but like I see this one here at the $20 one. This is from VK. He says,
love your videos. Use them in my introductory linguistics classes.
Thank you for what you do. And thank you, Sue. Thank you very much VK.
I appreciate that. Uh,
I appreciate the super chat and I appreciate that you're sharing my videos and
I'm really happy that you, uh, find them that valuable. Um,
the audio is low. Let me see. Um, hold on a second.
Did the audio just drop out now?
[Inaudible].
Did the audio just drop out now? Uh, or was it like, was it low the whole time?
So what happened was my headphones were really loud,
so I turned them off and maybe that interfered with the microphone
you got is fine. Okay, good, good, good. I just,
I see some comments off to the side on my iPhone. Okay.
Um, let me see. I think that was the last slide actually. Oh, I had one more.
So the content becomes your textbook when you're dealing with authentic content
as your textbook, but you can also take part in the comments.
That's one of the great things about social media.
If you're using it for productive purposes, that you can take part and, uh,
and you can engage with people. So if there's an interesting news article, uh,
you can,
you can comment on it and you can respond to other comments in the target
language. And that becomes quite fun. And it's like a memorable experience.
It's just like having a conversation with someone in the target language.
It's more memorable than studying in your textbook because you're engaging with
a real person. So that gives you that, um, more valuable, um,
more relevant memory that will help you remember the language that you use.
So it's really a good experience to, to take part in the comments,
if you have no one to actually speak to face-to-face. Okay.
So those are my ideas. Um, maybe they're, they're basic ideas.
There's nothing revolutionary there,
but I just wanted to share some ideas about what you can do at home.
If you're stuck under lockdown or semi locked down,
or you are not comfortable going out that much.
So it's a time that we can use to be more productive. Um, you know, it's not,
it's not a good situation, but at the very least,
maybe we can just make use of that time so that it's not an entirely bad
situation.
So let me have a look at the comments and let's see if there's anything more
that, that I can respond to here. Um,
I'm looking at them on my phone and they, the fly by rapidly.
So I'll just try to catch a few comments here and there.
Wow. Does he go on a fast?
Okay. I can scroll back. Uh, I can scroll back and see the,
the earlier comments too. That's good. So I don't lose them entirely.
I wish I knew how to see the actual stream on the computer, on the PC screen,
because it's much bigger and easier to find comments.
Yes.
Someone says, I love your videos and you and deed I'd asked for.
What did you say? I'd asked you about a video of Slovak.
Do you know anything about, do you know anything about it? Uh, Slovak? Well,
I know it's a Slavic language, but I don't know a lot about it specifically.
I'd have to look into it. Paul,
do you recommend native subtitles for super beginners?
Super beginners? Well, I'm have,
I have to think about that for a second for super beginner subtitles.
So you mean like if you're watching a movie in French,
should you turn on the French subtitles if you're a complete beginner? Yeah,
I think there's value in that. Um, but it depends. It depends. I mean it,
because sometimes there are very simple conversations in TV shows and movies.
So you might pick up on some basic readings and, um,
just a few basic words here and there, you know, good morning, how are you?
What are you doing? Things like that. Um, but at the same time,
movies and TV shows have a lot of language. That's not very natural. It's,
it's sort of crafted to be extra interesting.
So a lot of the things they say are not really good examples of how people
actually speak. So, uh, it can't be good. It's not bad.
[Inaudible].
Let me see. Repent everyone. The wrath of God is nearby. Cool.
Um, link focus. You can open a different tab with the stream open. Yeah,
I tried that, but let me, let me try it again. Let's see.
[Inaudible].
Someone asked what are the Kyushu dialects like, uh,
compared to the Osaka and Tokyo dialects, to be honest,
I don't know that much about, um, QSU dialects. Um,
yeah, I haven't spent that much time in Kyushu,
so I don't really know a lot about them.
[Inaudible].
Uh, someone said Paul, the microphone you're using a site address.
You should speak into the side of it for better audio quality.
I believe there's a blue led light, uh, led on sentence side. Okay.
This is, um, Samsung meteor mic. Uh,
so I should speak into the side. There's a blue light on it.
I have to figure this out.
I'll look more into this for next time. Now it's actually falling off the table.
[Inaudible].
Sorry. I win the award for most unprepared live stream today.
Oh my God. I have no fun stuff to post on Facebook. Okay.
Well only serious stuff. Only serious stuff.
Well, Facebook is a nightmare.
If you post only serious stuff or read serious stuff,
I installed an app on Facebook that blocks the word Trump,
because I saw nothing, but people fighting about Trump all the time.
And that's a whole massive distraction. I don't want to think about it.
[Inaudible].
Hey, Paul,
my book cheers about toasting in 80 foreign languages and about culture is
being published next spring. Cheers. That sounds cool. It's about toasting.
How to toast in different languages. Hm. Interesting.
Yeah. I want to ask someone, um, I asked them, how do you toast in Arabic?
Because I thought, Hmm. In predominantly Muslim cultures,
maybe they don't actually have a word for the toast because they don't drink
alcohol or at least, you know, it's more conservative.
People don't drink alcohol. Someone told me, they say handle ULI,
but I don't know if that's correct or not. So if someone knows,
please write that in the comments. I want to know.
[Inaudible].
Uh, someone said, what's your favorite place in Japan?
My favorite place in Japan? Well, it's a two-part answer. Uh,
I love Osaka because I've lived here for a long time. So it's basically my home,
but I also love Tokyo because Tokyo is, Oh,
we're back. Okay. Camera died for a second. What's up with that?
Okay. And the notice the notification was in Japanese,
I guess that's geo-targeting they know what country I'm in. Yeah. Um,
Tokyo is where all the action's at. That's where, you know,
a lot of my good friends live, uh, friends with both Osaka and Tokyo,
but Tokyo is awesome because there's just so much going on there. Um, Insta,
a lot of people there are doing cool stuff, starting businesses and,
um,
working in jobs that most of the international community and all soccer are not
working in most of the international community and Osaka movies,
Westerners they're teaching. Right.
But in Tokyo you get people doing all sorts of different work and, um,
yeah, it can be inspiring and interesting.
It's exciting to meet people who are doing something different.
So I like Alyssa that's all right. Like Tokyo or soccer is cool as well.
[Inaudible].
Well, complimentary comments. Thank you very much.
Let me look at the super chats again.
I'm not good at keeping track of all this stuff. And then VK,
I sit next to him before. Thanks again, VK. And we have Ben sack,
Ben, um, S E a C.
I don't know how to pronounce that said if you ever thought of doing a video on
old English, that'd be pretty interesting. Anyway.
Thanks for the great content you put out.
This is one of the few channels I always look forward to watching. Thank you,
Ben. I appreciate that. Yeah. I have thought about doing a video on old English,
to be honest, I've thought about all of them.
I have a lot of topics on my list that I intend to do. Uh,
it's just hard to get to them because each video takes so long to make
And another $20. Wow. You guys are generous and I appreciate the super chats.
Thank you so much. Uh, more sharp, 12. You are amazing. No,
I think you are amazing for shark 12 and that's a cool name.
The sharpest boring
Russia. Did you donate twice?
Did you send two $20 super chats or is that,
is that one with two messages? If you sent two of them. Whoa,
thank you. Anyway, I really, really appreciate super chats.
I don't expect to get them, but that's really cool. And MLK. Okay.
55 something. What's is that, um, Norwegian currency? What is an,
okay. I love your channel.
And I've been a subscriber for over five years. I think I'm curious.
How do you choose? Let me see that again. I lost it.
Well now I can't see it.
Let me find it again. Okay.
How do you choose what language to learn and how do you start? Well,
I don't really choose what language to learn. The language chooses me.
It's all based on irrational motivation. Um,
if I was choosing logically, then I would have gone all in on Spanish and uh,
really learned it. Uh, but he learned it well.
So I would be able to make content about Spanish, which would be super popular,
but instead I'm studying Indonesian right now.
I'm trying to get to a C1 level and Indonesian. I'm probably at a,
a B2 level right now,
but I want to get to see one Indonesian is a big language.
A lot of people speak it spoken by, well,
if you include Malai then maybe 270,
280 million people or something like that. Uh, it's a,
it's a widely spoken language,
but it's not popular as a language to study amongst people around the world. Uh,
but I think it will be in the future, but yeah,
I just choose which language to study based on what grabs me.
There's no logic to it.
There's a delay. Okay. Yeah. There's kind of, there's some, some delay.
I think my computer is actually slowing down.
My computer is getting overloaded. So there's a bit of a problem with a
bit of a problem with the sync.
Hello from Greece. What have you studied? Are you a linguist? Well,
I don't think of myself as a professional linguist, uh, because I don't,
I don't professionally spend my time researching, uh,
researching linguistics. Uh, but I,
I do use linguistics in my job.
I teach English as a foreign language in the university and I've done that for a
long time and that's applied linguistics and it involves a lot of elements of
linguistics. Um, but my dedication to languages in general,
that's basically just my passion. I'm a language enthusiast.
I just love languages and linguistics and I have for a long time.
So that's not really my profession. It's my passion.
Someone said, are there any languages or projects you started,
but couldn't finish. Uh,
I don't know if you mean videos or just languages that I tried to learn and
couldn't really get very far with them. Um, yeah, I mean,
there've been plenty, plenty of those. Plenty of both.
I've had to stop some videos in the middle when I was researching because it was
too difficult and I couldn't make sense of the topic. Uh,
and I've started studying some languages.
Usually I was excited in the beginning to start a language. Um,
in these cases, like when I stopped early on,
I was excited in the beginning to start studying this particular language.
But once I got to the difficult parts,
then I realized I wasn't as motivated as I thought. And, um, I,
it was just more the novelty, the idea of learning that language was cool,
but I wasn't motivated enough to get through the difficulty of it.
So that's where the irrational motivation comes in.
If I choose a language just based on logic, like this one would be useful,
you know, I never go very far with it.
I think it's about time to end the stream. You guys, because it's late here,
it's after midnight and my neighbors can hear me and they are starting to bang
with a broom. So it's time to go to bed, but, um,
I hope everyone stays healthy and keep safe out there wherever you are. Um,
I know, you know, America is having a lot of trouble right now.
I know Italy is still in a bad condition,
a lot of Europe and you know, everywhere basically.
So I hope everyone stays safe and healthy as much as possible.
And I'm also hope that you are taking care of yourself at home.
Um, trying to stay, stay positive and,
and healthy and happy and productive when you're stuck at home. All right.
So thank you very much, everyone have a good nights.
It's time to get some sleep, but I'll see you soon in the next video.
Have a good night and VK. Thanks again. Oh,
VK said stay safe and you donated again crazy, man. Well, thank you so much.
I love you guys. All right. Good night.
[Inaudible].